皆さん視力どうですか？
まあ、僕だと仕事上パソコンを見たり
ゲームする時間がすごい長いんでぇ
だんだん目が悪くなってきてるんで
たぶんね
ホントはメガネかけないと
いけないぐらいの視力になってるんですよ。
視力復活させるならメガネだということで
(説明書を読むはじめ)
やばい
は、初めて買ったからわかんないwww
初めて買ったからわかんないんですけど
メガネを買いました！！！！！！！！
で、
開けましてー(?)
メガネ「やあ」
おぉ～
こ、これかぁ～(^0_0^)
はい、このメガネ
なんか普通のメガネっぽく見えるんですけども～
なんとこのメガネ...
絶対かどうかはちょっと自信ないんですけど...
メガネ付けてて不便だと思う時って
あると思うんですよ。(ある)
メガネって運動したり
動いたりするとメガネ外れるんですよね。
それが嫌なんですけども
なんとこちらのメガネ
これなんかすごいな
なんか独特な形してますねほら
こちらのメガネですね
なんと
付けると外れなくなるメガネらしいです！
だとしたら画期的よ♡
これ付けながら走ったりできますからね。
果たしてどういう仕組みなんでしょうか？
なんかここがすごいくねくねしますね
でそれが両方に付いてる感じですね。
これ付けてもうメガネ取れないんだったら
俺ずっと付けてたいよって思うくらいなんですけど～
どうでしょうか???
あら、お似合いですね。
ヒュンッ
まってまってまって
え、まってまってうそでしょ
今付けてる感じだとマジで落ちないすね。
はじめレース開催中
え、まってやべ脳震盪脳震盪
今んとこ落ちないぞぉ
普通になんかこういう動きしても
落ちることはまず無さそうですね。
え、すごいすごいすごい
どういう仕組みなんだろう??
外すとポコポコってなってるんだよな
これも謎だな...
仕組みはよくわかんないんですけど、
多分この輪っかとかが
うまいこと耳に引っかかって
完全に落ちない仕組みになってるんでしょうね。
ですがあああああああ
私の目は～そう簡単に騙せない☆
メガネなだけに
今普通に付けてブンブン振っても
外せなかったんですけども
果たして絶対外れないって
どこまで外れないのか
検証してみようと思います。
なんかよくあることですよ
メガネ付けてて 「あっあれすると外れるちゃうな」とか
あると思うんですけども